Cantor's staying it today mm-hmm our
first one is from norm Schmitt from Tel
Aviv Israel oh wow now I'm out here no
I'm from Tel Aviv he's a no no is no one
gonna get you straight out of Tel Aviv
Israel that's right from the
[ __ ] Holy Land man oh [ __ ]
watching me some oh my
anyway got Timmy to distinguish from you
guys
furniture ba I recently went to see that
new that New Avengers movie which is
dope by the way and I went to go see it
alone I went by myself reason I went by
myself is cuz i don't know none of my
friends schedule schedules were like
sniff it was mine so i just went to see
it when i'm marvel movie drops i'm going
to watch that [ __ ] gang bro yeah
so anyway my king understand for you
guys is uh what do you think about going
to the movies by yourself king it or
sting it me let me know and just for the
record I'm not the guy sitting in the
back jerking off right I'm sitting front
and center man I'm watching it moment
time over
respect brother myself yeah buzz a real
hero like Ned Stark or Noam stark right
there yes and bro shout out to be here
with Brennan Shabbat I saw pretty [ __ ]
out but uh yeah man sit in the front of
you in a jerk-off dude don't be a little
wiener you know sit I'll be upfront
about it so you'll get arrested yeah
brah you know what yourself some
raisinettes and jackoff yeah I don't
know who the Avenger I mean I know that
Captain America is in there but also
whoever else brah mighty Fauntleroy
whoever the [ __ ] the Avengers are get up
there and jerk off with the best of them
beat the world you know what I'm saying
shoutout it uh Tel Aviv sounds like you
had some busy friends if he doesn't know
their schedule and maybe just text them
and see if they're available to hang out
for the movie but they don't have text
in the Holy Land a Senate pigeon
yeah you've to send a pigeon or a raven
if the paint a raven white and [ __ ]
tell him it's like it or they just pray
on it and hope movie times work out in
that crazy in the olden days for like
two because the raven a dove was
expensive so they they'd whiten up a
raven and it's not really that like it
Raven yeah because you get a raven easy
they would sammy sosa the ravens exactly
so so raven i yeah that's dope do that
is row and then they also at some point
in time in history of time they had on
because then you would just kill
something the Ravens would show up
they're easy to get doves
today you get them the rats of the sky
baby no yeah yeah agent you idiot I mean
you're nice you're right dude
hamsters are the [ __ ] doves of this
guy no hamsters are land animals dude
agree no I know but if you're but
they're the if you know you don't know
how gravity works yeah you don't know
let's move on no thank you
wait well answer his question what's he
to go tomorrow move by self grown-up man
I saw a Spencer a Pet Detective Rowan up
he move this week no I'm my mama and
miss Q I saw it six days in a row by
myself now I was a grown man with a kid
can't be going by myself anymore
little weird but when I was younger I
just be super gangster about it go all
the time by my silly King that [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] your friends
hashtag no new friends well look no I
must say that that you know a lot of
time it's basically you're just
auditioning for virtual reality when you
go to movie by yourself you know you're
just making a see if it's possible from
one day to you to be completely enclosed
in a place where you'll know everyone's
schedules you can put on a VR you'll
know everyone's schedules you know a
fair you'll stop by and say hey T right
in front of you if you wanted to or
whatever you know maybe a truck full of
fresh apples will just capsize right
next to you and you'll have whatever you
possible virtual reality your audition
for that right now brother so I think
you're doing well also you're in the
Gaza Strip dude you might never even see
this video you could have you know
caught a bomb to the jaw right now or a
rhino I just won't do a rock yeah just
that's what they do over there the rocks
oh dude
you've seen the videos throw them into
holders bro brother Palestinians a
[ __ ] they got a lease issue on the
land so they're figuring it out dude so
if you're still alive gnomes shout out
brah be saying out to that dude man see
whatever you can while you're alive
brother dude but also don't waste time
trying to get a girl and take her to the
movies get one of them cyber BOTS yeah
yeah dude you're a living halfway
virtual just get a girl yeah get a robot
dude dude get a robot you're
you're in Israel Bronstein he's Jewish
dude who else [ __ ] uh Larry David
Larry David you did a sitcom get a robot
fran drescher now definitely dude
some Jewish women can be really [ __ ]
angry so you might out again yeah make
it them up yeah a funny movie yeah [ __ ]
that guy yeah
there you go gang broccolini